[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es eine neue kategorie
wir machen die kategorie s6 rezepte und
zwar haben schon ganz viele männer
zuschauer gefragt sally macht doch
einfach mal diese magie oder knorr
rezepte ganz fix nach aber ohne töte und
das machen wir heute und heute starten
wir mit einem richtig schnellen gericht
und zwar gibt es eine hak reispfanne und
das ganze dauert echt nicht länger als
30 minuten
ich mache das hat vielleicht sogar noch
selber da rechne ich dann fünf minuten
länge 1
aber ansonsten habt ihr wirklich
innerhalb von 30 minuten ein fertiges
gericht für vier personen auf dem tisch
stehen
das schmeckt mir schmeckt den kindern
und schmeckte morath richtig gut und vor
allem habe ich die meisten zutaten immer
zu hause
ich zeige euch mal eben kurz die zutaten
für die reispfanne verwende ich etwas
olivenöl 400 gramm rinder hackfleisch
eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe 2 rote
paprika eine gelbe paprika 400 gramm
tomaten aus der dose 125 gramm
gemüsebrühe etwas zucker paprikapulver
und oregano 250 gramm naturreis salz und
pfeffer ich nehme jetzt die
paprikaschoten und da könnt ihr einfach
mit dem daumen
hier in der mitte den strunk eindrücken
dann schneide ich unten gerne den boden
weg und stand die vier saiten und dann
habt ihr einfach genug diesen kleinen
rest hier und alles andere könnte er
verwerten und essen und dann schneide
ich die paprika einfach in zwei bis drei
zentimeter große quadrate
[Musik]
man können in der zwischenzeit auch
schon mal einen esslöffel öl in einem
großen topf erhitzen dass wir einen pot
gericht das heißt ihr nehmt euch direkt
am anfang gleich einen großen topf da
ist es einfach mein lieblings topf
[Musik]
unternehmen die einfach die paprika
stücke die kommen hier direkt in den
heißen topf und werden dann für etwa
drei bis vier minuten angebraten nicht
möglich später dass die pappe das stück
zu imbiss haben macken so gerne wenn
gemüse zu weit wird deswegen nehme ich
die auch gleich wieder raus
das haben sie schon mal ein schönes
resta roma dann aus der pfanne nehmen
und in der gleichen pfanne erhitzt sich
jetzt das übrige öl und brate das
fleisch an und ich mach mein hackfleisch
immer ganz gerne selbst zum hackfleisch
herstellen verwende ich gerne
rinderhalter hat nämlich den perfekten
fettanteil und ich nehme einfach die
kitchenaid schüssel aber diese ein
bisschen groß daher nehme ich jetzt zum
erhöhen einfach nur die schüssel
obendrüber meine schlüssel wo ich
fleisch drin haben möchte und dann wenn
ich schon mal hackfleisch mache hole ich
gleich eine große menge und kann es
nämlich auch fasziniert ein film das
fleisch schon einfach schön in lange
streifen zu schneiden
also nicht würfeln sondern er so lange
dünne streifen dann geht es nämlich am
besten auch hier durch die schnecke im
fleischwolf
ich habe jetzt folgende mittlere scheibe
und kann hier ist einfach fleisch
herstellen was auch mittlerer stufe etwa
bei stufe 4 und wichtig ist nicht
drücken sondern den fleischwolf selbst
arbeiten machen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich es hier in der heißen
pfanne schön krümelig anbraten
jetzt ist das hackfleisch krümmel nicht
angebracht die zwiebel und knoblauch
sehr habe ich jetzt auch schon fein
gewürfelt und die werden jetzt mit
gebraten
ich glaube wir servieren dazu wieder
joghurt oder schmand gerichten mag ich
das echt super gerne
dann lösche ich das ganze jetzt mit den
tomaten aus der dose ab im sommer
nämlich da auch keine frische ansonsten
aber lieber aus der dose weil ich schon
bereit sind dann die gemüsebrühe dazu
dann noch direkt die gewürze ein
bisschen zucker paprika salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
und je nachdem welchen reise nimmt
könnte jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr
wasser oder gemüsebrühe zufügen
ich nenne es noch ein bisschen dazu ich
habe nämlich einen naturreis dem es ein
paar grad uhr reist und der hat einfach
noch alle nährstoffe
da wird einfach durch druck und durch
dampf werden die nährstoffe von der
schale ins innere gepresst so hat man
alle nährstoffe noch drin
und der hat auch nur eine garzeit von
zehn minuten ihr könnt natürlich auch in
weißem reis nehmen aber ich hab doch
schon immer darauf dass ich dann an
naturreis habe dass man einfach mehr mit
nährstoffe mit dabei hat so kommt der
reiz hier mit rein und dann kommt jetzt
hier der deckel drauf kurz abschmecken
vorher ob salz und pfeffer passt gerne
noch chili zufügen aber das mache ich
später bei mir einfach in einen teller
wegen den beiden hier und je nach bedarf
für dich noch mal ein bisschen wasser
dazu oder lass das weg und lasse jetzt
kurz aufkochen und dann bei niedriger
stufe etwa acht minuten köcheln und zwei
minuten vorher also nach acht minuten
zehn minuten brauchte er insgesamt nach
acht minuten werde ich dann die paprika
noch dazu geben dass die einfach schön
bissfest bleibt und dann ist es gericht
und fertig also echt ein superschnelles
gericht und ich werde es in der
zwischenzeit schon mal den joghurt mit
salz und pfeffer abschmecken und
vielleicht nur ein bisschen knoblauch
einreiben
das mögen wir ganz gerne und aufräumen
und dann kann man tischdecken okay
dann kommen jetzt die paprikaschoten
dazu ich lasse jetzt auch mal so oben
drauf liegen dann einfach noch mal zwei
minuten nach jahren und dann gleich
verlieren
[Musik]
sosa mehr ackern wir probieren mal ich
es gerne mit reis und damit meine ich
damit die lupe
ich würde jetzt bei mir noch ein
bisschen chili drauf machen aber es
macht mir dann auf meinen eigenen teller
gehört haben wir nicht so scharf ist
wobei er ist schon ein bisschen scharf
ganz im gegensatz zu anderen definitiv
mehr joghurt wir sind so die fraktion
joghurt reicht heißt dass die anderen
noch was haben sie auch gleich zum essen
einladen
wir brauchen heute nichts mehr kochen
und ich mag vor allem den naturreis der
hat nämlich noch schön bist der wird
nicht zu weit da wird nicht matschig und
man sieht auch hier ganz gut dass der
einfach schön und locker erst nach dem
kochen und das mag ich echt und den
rezepten ganz gerne
falls sie das rezept dach machen wollt
dann steht es auch salehs - blog.de
und falls es noch magie oder knorr
rezepte gibt die ich für euch nach
machen soll schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
dann gucke ich mal welches die
beliebtesten sind und dann mache ich
sehr gerne für euch nach also bis zum
nächsten mal
viel spaß beim kochen und wirklich nur
eine halbe stunde dauert nicht länger
und machen wir so einen kleinen
nachtisch und dann geht es raus dabei
heute zur stürme strophen vielleicht
bleiben heute auch drinnen oder japan
[Musik]